欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们来讲一下关于产品优化的一些具体的实操方法
这里我已经帮大家总结好一个完整的框架
那么大家可以按照这个框架去进行优化就可以了
因为很多时候我们看起来具优化产品
缺少思路跟方法都是因为我们没有完整的框架
你会感觉到好像要处理的内容非常多
所以说你在调整的时候就会束手无策
这次一定要把这个框架掌握了
那么你后面去优化就非常有真正性
是相线优化法
主要是通过捉住核心的几个指标
就能够构建一个比较完整的框架
比如说我们这里主要捉住的就是曝光量和点击量
这两个核心的指标来进行判断和进行对应的指标优化的
比如说我们这个板块主要重视在高曝光低点击这个板块的进行优化
也就是我这里分了四项线
横坐标是点击量
重坐标是曝光量
那么我们根据高曝光低点击你看地上线就是高曝光低点击
那么这个板块是重点优化的板块
那么如何优化呢
第一个就是我们先要去看这个产品的流量来源
主要是关键词的时候我们要去查一下这些关键词的准确性
那么怎么查它的准确性呢
第一个你把这个关键词放在国际站首页去搜索
第二个就是你把这个词拿到谷歌去搜索
去看图片
是不是跟你们现在推广的这款产品的款式风格属性等等
非常的相似
如果在国际站首页和谷歌搜索出来的结果
跟你们的产品极为相似的
那么说明你们这个词是相对来说准确的
这种准确的词我们还要去查一下它的排名
如果它的排名太靠后面了
则我们需要去推广提升它的排名
因为这个有可能是因为你的词排名在首页的底部这些广告位
或者是第二第三页这边
所以才会导致你的产品出现高曝光低点击的情况
并不是因为你的主图问题
所以这是第一个维度
从此去查询
第二个维度就是
你的价格启定量物流费用评分
这些因素都不符合买家的需求
当买家搜索一个关键词的时候
你的产品在首页展示给客户的时候
客户看到这些核心的数据
他发现他接受不了你们的价格或者是启定量太高了
付流费太贵了或者是评分太低了
他就直接不点击你们的产品了
所以就会导致高曝光低点击
所以这个维度要去细分
第三个就是内幕曝光导致
通常这种情况是会持续几天的
这种情况其实可以不用理
因为这种情况一般来说都是比较短暂的
那么怎么知道它是内幕曝光呢
比如说你的产品总的曝光量1000
但是呢你在词报告里面去看
它的曝光量可能就是3040
说明什么
说明如果是300的话
那么这里还有1000减300还有700
说明这700的曝光可能都是从内幕来的
或者是搜索图片来的
所以这种情况下
你就不需要去理它
而是先关注最后面
如果上面这些问题都不大
那么有可能你的主图可能实在是太差了
可以进行主图更换
去测试就可以了
这是重点优化的板块
第一向线一定要重点优化
也就是高曝光低点击这个维度重点优化
我已经把这个色块标出来了
而且我的框架就是根据曝光跟点击这个维度来进行判断的
那么第二向线就是不优化
我们重点关注
这个板块主要靠点击率来衡量
比如说你的点击率在0.8到4%属于正常的
这个产品就不需要优化
那么我们看这个数据可以按照周的维度来进行去查看它这些
就可以了不要按天
如果按天的话数据基数太少不够准确
那么这个区间我们重点关注什么
一个是循环跟TM的转化
因为你这里是高点击
这个时候你就要去看它点击来的这么多访客
能不能给你带来循环
如果点击来的这么多访客都不能带来循环
那么你就要去关注一下具体的问题到底是什么
那么接下来第三项线就是
是低曝光
低点击你看双低两个都是低的
这种情况呢我们其实不用优化了
直接做重大的调整就可以了
比如说你发的产品超过了60天
这种产品超过60天的你就没必要优化了
因为平台对超过60天的产品
90天的产品是没有流量扶持的
所以说这种情况如果不是特别重要的产品超过60天的我建议是不优化了
我们重点优化什么呢
我们重点去看近30天内发的产品
如果它的流量极少极少也就是低曝光低点击就说明它的流量非常的少
这种情况我们最直接的方式就是去改标题
直接去找到那些最近增长流量的关键词
直接替换到这些产品的标题里面去再关注一段时间看看它是否有改善
那么这个板块就是按照这个思路去做就可以了
至少能够给你减少很多不必要的劳动
不用占用太多的时间在这个板块
最后一个第四项线就是低曝光高点击量
说明什么这种情况呢
说明你的产品很好
产品很好
但是你的低曝光
为什么低曝光一个字太少了
使得覆盖少
第二个就是你的词的本身的流量就少
也就是说要么你的标题用的词太少
要么你标题用的词很多
但是都是平台搜索指数很低的词
所以才会导致你的曝光量是相对低的
第三个有可能你的用的这些词虽然说有流量
但是呢它的排名太低了
排名低是不是会出现有可能就是竞争不到流量
如果你排名低的话可能排在第二第四页
那么是不是客户搜索的时候可能只看第一页
第二第三第四页都不看了
所以说你的曝光量就非常低
因为你能够进入第一页的机会很少
但是呢总体来说很高点击说明什么
说明很多客户都喜欢你们的这个产品
说明你们这个产品是非常好的
而且是比较受市场欢迎的
所以才会出现低曝光量高点击量
那么针对这个板块我们如何去优化呢
针对第四个板块我们是增加资源去扶持的
第一个比如说你的这个产品
A是不推广的产品是吧
如果你去判断这个产品
它的一个访客国家是精准的
是精准的是OK的
那么第二个就是它是有商机的比如说有TM
有寻盘的
它的关键词也是OK的也是精准的
那么这几种情况下
第一个情况第二个情况第三个情况下
那么这种产品我们可以直接推广
推广了就可以增加它的曝光量
增加它的曝光量的目的就是让更多的人看到
看到了之后它是不是有可能增加你的点击量
增加你的点击量
会不会就有概率增加你的群盘跟TM的转化
是吧这个逻辑
那么第二种情况这个产品已经是推广了
比如说B这款产品已经是在直动车推广中的
这种情况下它获得的流量少是吧
因为它曝光嘛所以说它本身获得的流量少
可能你这个B产品在计划里面得到的流量太少了
所以这个时候我们要调整一下我们的直动车
把流量倾斜到B这款产品上面
怎么样倾斜呢
第一个如果你是关键值推广
你可以增加与B这款产品相关的关键值进行推广
或者是说提升与B相关的关键值的一个出价
那么它就有机会获得流量了
第二个就是你可以降低B这个计划里面的其他产品的一个
加产品的一个流量消耗减少他们的花钱
那么怎么减少呢
那么降低他们的那些相关的关键值的出价就可以了
或者是说你把这个计划跟B同一个计划的
产品A消耗非常多的钱的这个产品直接暂停
占领它这个时候也有可能就是B能够获得更多的流量
那么这个关于推广产品的时候
我们直接调整自动车清洗流量就可以了
接着第三种情况就是如果你的产品低曝光高点击的
那么这个时候我们为了拉升
曝光量是不是要给它增加更多的一个资源的扶持
比如说把这个产品加入橱窗
加入主营认证绑定问顶绑定顶长
这些都有利于提升这个产品的一个整体的一个曝光量
来获取更多的点击来达到更多的询盘和贴目
你解吗
第四步也是一样的增加资源的扶持
比如说做EDM营销反客营销直播
把这个产品划到直播间
那么这个板块也是能够增加它的点击
来拉升它的询盘跟贴目的
所以我们整条链路都是为了让整个产品的转化更好
我们优化的时候按照这四个项线去选择产品
和去判断哪些该优化哪些不该优化
把不该优化的就不要去花太多的时间去浪费在上面
重点关注的就第一第四项线
这些就要重点的花时间跟精力去做
那么这个时候我们整个店铺的产品才能够往一个正向的方向发展
其实看了这么多优化的内容
实际上只要你记住两个核心的指标就可以了
报光量跟点击量
那么你再根据这四个项线去重点选择产品
然后根据产品的数据表现各种形式
你要去按照这种步骤一个个去优化
前期可能记不住那么多东西
但是你要按照自己的理解多去操作实践几遍
就能够把这个框架记下来了
我们标话的话一般来说
曝光量跟点击量的一个重要的衡量就是点击率
因为有曝光还到点击是吧
所以中间这个衡量指标就是点击率
通过这个点击率的衡量
它是否有效或者是说它是否在一个合理的范围
最后面我们来强调一个指标也就是点击量
点击量你看这一条线这是低点击量而高点击量
这边不是复数啊
比如说我的判断标准是以10个点击为起点
超过10个点击的算是高点击量
低于10个点击的是低点击量
当然这个10只是我的一个参考值
你可以设置成15或者20或者是30
因为你们店铺里面的产品的数量以及点击量都差距很大的
所以说这个指标你要根据自己的店铺来进行一个设置去选择优化
比如说你的是个门产品
通常它的点击量都是非常高的
而且你们店铺可能是几千上万个产品
那么产品实在是太多了是吧
如果产品太多那么你把这个点击量设置高一点
比如说你20起那么你能选择的产品优化的产品就会相对来说少一点
如果你也按照10个点击量来起步去优化的话
那么你整个店铺如果是上万个产品
又是热门行业的话
那么你这个就会发现非常多的产品需要你去优化
这就增加了你工作量而且有效性是比较低的
如果你是冷门行业的你就一定按照10这个起步
比如说你冷门行业可能就是600个产品是吧
5到600个产品
你的本身店铺的流量就本身就几少了
能够有10个点击的产品都是非常少的
那么这种情况你不一定说要设置10
可能你要设置的是8个点击
我也去按照这个上线来进行优化
或者是说你也按照标准10个点击去优化就可以了
所以说这个冷门行业跟热门行业
它选择的一个指标是可以根据你自己店铺的实际情况来调整的
因为这个衡量的一个起始的数值会决定着你需要优化产品的数量
所以我们一定要根据自己的店铺去把这个数值确定下来
再去优化一定要灵活变通一点
那么这节课我们就讲了关于曝光量点击量这个四项线的优化方法
如果你还没有足够的清晰
建议你多听一次再根据店铺里面的实际案例去操作一次
那么我相信一定能够帮你更好的理解产品如何去优化
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里